foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the dust is still settling on Thursday's
Autumn statement but a potential new row
over brexit might be about to disturb
the uneasy truths among different wings
of the conservative party the Sunday
Times claims that ministers are
considering a closer Swiss style
relationship with the EU now for most
people of course the immediate concern
is the economy inflation hit 11 last
month and we're told the UK is probably
already in a recession that could be the
longest on record or that as the NHS is
showing increasing signs of real strain
with waiting lists and waiting times
soaring and of course we're still a
couple of months from the depths of
winter we'll discuss it all with our
guests this morning in just a moment we
will be hearing from the Health and
Social care secretary Stephen Barkley
for labor we'll talk to the party's
Shadow work and pensions secretary
Jonathan Ashworth
now the NHS Confederation represents the
health system in England Wells and
Northern Ireland we'll talk to its chief
executive Matthew Taylor
we'll also be talking about awab ishak
he's a little boy who died after
developing a respiratory condition from
living in a moldy flat we'll talk to the
social housing activist kwajo twinny boa
and the former children's commissioner
and Longfield will also be on the
program this morning
[Music]
good morning now it could be an
exceptionally difficult winter for the
NHS record waiting times hundreds of
thousands of nurses threatening to
strike and soaring inflation squeezing
budgets when our health did get extra
cash in the Autumn statement this week
but social care reform was yet again
delayed a little earlier I spoke to the
house secretary Steve Barkley
we've just had another cop agreement
where the wealthier countries are
agreeing to send more money to Aid those
who need more assistance to tackle
climate change obviously for many people
they will see that as a great idea but
some of our viewers might be thinking
Hang on we're in a cost of living crisis
here at the minute our debt interest
payments are soaring can we really
afford to do this
well the detail is still coming in that
was obviously agreed overnight so we
need to look at that detail as we get
more information but of course the UK
through its overseas a budget has always
played a role in terms of tackling
climate change as supporting countries
around the world in terms of the
measures they're taking so we need to
look at whatever's been agreed in The
Wider context of our International Aid
package and now I want to talk to you
about the NHS there's lots I want to
talk to you on that however before we do
and the Sunday Times is reporting on
brexit that the government is
considering a Swiss style relationship
with the European union now that would
mean relatively frictionless trade but
it would also mean paying more money
into the EU budget and almost certainly
higher immigration plus an increased
role for the European courts of Justice
too do you recognize these reports no I
don't and if you look at the Autumn
statement what the chancellor set out
was our determination to maximize the
brexit opportunities in her growth areas
whether that's in green Industries
whether it's in life sciences whether in
financial services and in fact there
were specific announcements in the
Autumn statement in terms of solvency
too we've got a prime minister who
himself supported brexit I myself did
and was brexit secretary and worked very
hard to maximize our control of our laws
our borders and our money so it's
absolutely important particularly in
those high growth sectors such as
Financial Services line sciences and the
green industries that we really use the
brexit freedoms we have and so I don't
recognize this story at all could you
ever support that kind of agreement well
I didn't support that I want to maximize
the opportunities that brexit that's
what I worked for as brexit secretary
and is the minister responsible for Life
Sciences I see huge opportunities for
the UK and being agilely moving at PACE
and having a regulatory system that is
absolutely tailored to the the UK needs
at the same time you know Jeremy Hunt
has said that he wants to remove the
vast majority of trade barriers with the
EU I mean if you're really serious about
doing that then this is the kind of
thing you need to look at isn't it well
the point is it's in both sides
interests to remove barriers we traded
with each other we're important Partners
to each other so that's mutually
beneficial and of course we want to work
constructively with EU Partners to do
that but that's not at the expense of
maximizing opportunities in high growth
sectors and the Autumn statement
signaled our determination to do that
for example with the announcement on
solvency too um I just want to talk
about the Autumn statement with regards
to brexit because the office of budget
responsibility you know the official
independent Watchdog were pretty clear
on what they thought about it they said
that brexit will result in the UK's
trade intensity being 15 lower in the
long run than if the UK had remained in
the EU the latest evidence suggests that
brexit has had a significant adverse
impact on UK trade
um and going on today via reducing both
overall trade volumes and the number of
trading relationships between UK and EU
firms do you accept that brexit has had
as the obr says a significant adverse
impact on UK trade well I think there's
dangers in looking at one little bit of
The Ledger in isolation if you look at
the vaccines rollout was technically
legally an EU member could have done
things differently I think culturally
the question would not have done so well
the question is do you accept brexit has
had a significant adverse impact on UK
trade well I think there's pros and cons
and the point is we have opportunities
we have opportunities through the
Divergence opportunities I've just
talked about things like solvency too to
get those Pension funds investing in
leveling up communities uh better
reflecting the needs of our financial
services specifically do you accept
brexit has had a significant adverse
impact on UK trade well what I'm saying
is you've got to look at the issues in
terms of brexit in the round there are
areas where there have been difficulties
in terms of Greater friction and we're
looking to work constructively with EU
Partners on that but equally there are
very significant opportunities as a
result of brexit I don't think we would
have done the vaccine rollout in the way
that we did had we remained a member of
the it sounds like and the significant
regulatory opportunities we have and the
Autumn statements signaled our
determination to take those you're clear
on what you see to be the kind of
positives and the opportunities but do
you accept it has had a significant
adverse impact on trade what I'm saying
is there's pros and cons it's very hard
it's very specific it's very hard to
model exactly what the impact would be
for example we've just been through well
has done that haven't they of course
that I know for my time when I was
brexit secretary just how difficult it
is to model these things of course we've
been through a pandemic that has had an
impact there's a range of things well
the point is what matters is we maximize
the freedoms that we have uh take those
particularly into the high growth
sectors such as in Digital Life Sciences
green technologies and financial
services and the Autumn statements
signaled I'm intent to do so okay now I
do want to move on to the NHS such an
important issue many of our viewers will
be really concerned about it and if I
may I just want to play to you what
happened when our correspondent phrase
Ward went to Rochdale for this program
to ask people about their experiences of
the NHS
a lot of people going to a e because
they can't get doctors appointment so
then they're
um working nine hours in a e which is
ridiculous I was a nurse and I do think
the standards gone down an awful lot
since I was nursing a lot could be done
to improve I think it's struggling it's
pushed for funding
um
he ran to wait for appointments a lot
longer than you were before not enough
doctors they're waiting times are too
long I took my daughter there last week
we were sat in there for six and a half
hours for staff we need
better stuff the waiting times just for
everything is too long as far as the
doctor's surgeries goes I can't get an
appointment it's shocking at the moment
and I live in Milton raw and my doctor's
surgery
it can be on your last legs and you
can't get an appointment
what's your response to that well when
Jeremy Hunt and I were last in the
Department of Health four years ago we
put in place the biggest ever increase
in medical undergraduate training at 25
increase those doctors obviously take
time to come on stream now become Junior
doctors in 2024 so that gives an
indication of our commitment to boosting
numbers we've got three percent more
doctors this year than last year and
we're looking also at how we boost the
wider Primary Care stuff we had a
Manifesto commitment on that and we're
on track to deliver it but I recognize
as a consequence of the pandemic GP
appointments have been under pressure we
all see more people 90 000 more G
appointments this year than last year
we're looking at what technology we can
offer some things like Cloud telephony
so we avoid the ATM sort of scramble of
calls to a GP on a Monday morning so
it's about the technology we put in
place it's about the wider skills and
boosting those numbers in primary care
but it's also about boosting the numbers
of GPS and that's what we did by opening
five new medical schools where students
started in 2019 but obviously there's a
time lag in those coming on stream
they're talking about doctors there
they're also talking about a e I just
want to show you the latest waiting
times graphic for a e
um it's pretty shocking you can see
there this is the number of patients
waiting more than 12 hours in a e
hitting over 43 000 in October now I
showed the same graph to Jeremy Hunt
when he was in the program and I put it
to him that you know this looks like a
Health Service on the brink of collapse
he said there are massive pressures on
the NHS and I think that doctors and
nurses on the front line are frankly
under unbearable pressure so I do
recognize the picture you say I mean do
you think the NHS is on the brink of
collapse well what that graph shows you
can see for example firstly that it's
very much driven by the pandemic in
terms of the the shoes I'm just asking
about that well let me come on to what
the situation yes and I recognize so I
recognize particularly for staff they're
under huge pressure in na nurses doctors
working for anomaly hard given what that
graph shows that is why in the Autumn
statement we prioritize in particular
social care 2.8 billion next year 4.7
billion at the year of after in 2024
we'll have 8 billion pounds going into
Health and Social care and the reason we
private prioritized both Health and
Social care is because of delayed
discharges
the key issue when you see that graph
the focus tends to be on a e or
ambulances what is causing that graph is
the 13 and a half thousand delayed
discharge which often links into social
care and that's why we've targeted
funding a very significant amount of
funding at a difficult time into social
care so we can tackle that delayed
discharge which ultimately is the way we
get the tones down just briefly because
you talked a lot about what you want to
do and I'll talk about your uh extra
decision making when it comes to
um quangos or um files or the
temperatures as well is putting it but
before we do do you accept there is a
problem with NHS right now that it's not
acceptable well I except it's under huge
pressure and that's because of the
pandemic let me give you one example the
the number of 52 weights for operations
was 1 300 going into the pandemic it's
now over 400 000. okay so this is
because of the pandemic we Face huge
pressures that's primarily the cause
what we've done is Target things like
delayed discharge which is the way we
get flow into hospitals which is
critical for shifting those numbers now
now the NHS got 3.3 billion pounds of
extra funding in the Autumn statement uh
but according to the man on Sunday
you're calling for a bonfire of the NHS
pen pushers what does that mean we've
got 6.6 billion over two years but it's
important that we get maximum value for
money from that and if I look for
example at the center at the Department
of Health and its Armstrong for what is
they collectively cost 2.8 billion
pounds and I think the scope is to look
at what the costs are in terms of
administration in the NHS how fewer
targets devolve more decision making we
now have we now have the integrated care
boards that can look at issues on a
population basis a much more localized
basis what I want to do is give more
autonomy more freedom to trust leaders
to our icbs so that they're not spending
so much time managing upwards which in
the feedback they give to me is a
constant source of frustration for them
so let's have a more streamlined Center
develop more decision making to those on
the ground that's a better just want to
talk about targets because you say that
you want to cut hundreds of targets but
you know targets are the way we monitor
NHS performance right you know the graph
that we just showed on a e waiting times
that's how we know there's an issue with
a e it's frankly how people like me can
hold people like you responsible is
there not a place for Targets in the NHS
they're important are they well there is
a place for targets but they've
everything's a priority nothing's
sobriety and risk in my view is best
assessed on a population basis through
the icbs by local leaders they're better
able to tailor the priorities for the
local needs and we will have information
such as important right of course of
course and no one's suggesting we don't
have any Targets but what I'm saying is
there's uh 2.8 billion pounds do you
want to get rid of the target such as
any waiting time no I think the a e is a
very useful Target in terms of actually
the wider system Health within the NHS
and it speaks to flow which is a key
issue in terms of ambulance under days
and people waiting in a e now another
big issue for you is strikes the Royal
College of Nursing striking for the
first time in its history now you told
the Sunday Telegraph their demands are
unreasonable and unaffordable what would
be a reasonable pay rise there and
nurses well what they're asking for is
17.6 that would be an extra cost for
nine billion pounds on the NHS budget
that for your viewers it is around three
times more than those in outside the
public sector are receiving and that's
why I think that is unreasonable and of
course whilst pay is important it's
important to look at the package in the
round the NHS contributes a fifth of a
nurse's salary into the pension with
their contribution on top that means a
quarter uh it goes into a nurse's
pension 33 days plus of annual leave so
it's important to look at the package as
around what would be a reasonable pay
rise do you think nurses pay should keep
up with inflation well we have a process
to to answer that question which is the
independent pay review body
because you've just described their
demands as unreasonable and affordable
so we know you can give your opinion
well and my opinion is we have a process
through the independent pay-per-view
body that is why last year nurses got
three percent when the rest of the
public sector had a pay freeze we have a
process through independent pay-per-view
body to look at these issues in the
round and of course Sophie it's not
simply about pay when I speak to nurses
but you also talk about the estate
that's why we're investing in 40 new
hospitals that's why we've got a
significant Capital program around the
surgical herbs the diagnostic Centers
it's also about technology one of the
big bears nurses tell me is often when
the tech actually makes their their job
difficult and and we haven't got the
right Tech in place so so it's not just
about pay it's about the wider
conditions and that's why I'm very keen
to engage with the Trade union as I saw
the General Secretary of Unison this
week I had a round table with Union news
I'm at the RCN also last week so I'm my
door is open we're engaging with the
trade unions there are other factors
alongside pay that we need to discuss
but we do have a process through the
independent pay-per-view body to look at
these issues now
um this week like so many of us I've
been really touched by the story of the
little boy the two-year-old who died
after he was living in a moldy flat and
we know of course the boss of the
housing provider has resigned and does
the government need to look at itself as
well I mean how are we living in a
country where a two-year-old boy can die
from the housing that he's living in
well it's heartbreaking isn't it and
aside from being a minister I'm also a
parent you know I've got two young
children and I think anyone sort of
looks at that you know regardless
actually whether a parent or not but I
think just as Citizens we look at that
story and you know it's it's a terrible
story and it's clear that it needs to be
followed through we need to look at what
lessons there are clearly there were
Fair of yours in terms of the way the
local Council acted I know it's
something that Michael and Michael Gove
is taking a very serious look at in a
very interested and it's uh it's
something that's heartbreaking for us
all to see do we need to brutally focus
on housing at the minute well I think we
need more housing we need to to boost
that I think that's important to
intergenerational fairness as well but I
think boosting housing is separate to
what were clearly some of areas here
where the family had raised concerns and
those were not acted on and and we need
to to look into that
finally World Cup starts today there's
been some concerns of course about
qatar's treatment of women the LGBT
community and also of course the migrant
workers many of whom were working on
these stadiums and yesterday there was
this extraordinary press conference from
the president of FIFA who said that the
one side side of morality lesson is just
hypocrisy and he said that Europe and
the West should be apologizing for what
we've been doing for 3000 Years Around
the World before giving moral lessons
what's your response to that uh well
it's an international uh major event and
I think all of us are excited we we
firstly wish the England team well uh
and also just on the subject as well a
huge shout out to everyone in rugby
league I think uh the tournament that
they've just had both the men's the
women's the wheelchair has been a
fantastic showcase for sports uh and for
rugby league in particular but obviously
in terms of Qatar it's important that we
engage I think everyone will want to get
behind the team and it's a major
tournament that we're very much looking
forward to I'm James cleverley the
former secretary said fan should respect
the law of the home country is it right
I think people should respect the law
whether that's overseas or in the UK
even if you don't agree with that we can
go along with it without respecting it
well I think the law of the land
wherever you go it's important to
respect yes okay
um you're gonna be watching the World
Cup of course who's your money on to win
yeah well like you I think we all want
uh England to win and uh you know that's
what we're backing yeah I definitely
want England to win but I'm not sure
that's where my money would be going
I'll be honest thank you very much for
being on the program today
my interview there with the house
secretaries Stephen Barkley now as usual
the tape will follow this program that's
just after 9 30. a chance to analyze the
interviews talk through news lines with
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
but I just wanted to get Sam's take on
that interview with Steve Barkley before
we move on and get Labor's uh take um
Sam there's quite a few news lines I
thought from that interview what stood
out to you
well Steve Barkley in many ways has just
one of the most difficult jobs in
government because he needs to be seen
really turning around the Health Service
in time for the next election no more
than two years away and you heard from
those voters that Fraser Maude was
talking to the sky correspondent about
just how badly people think that the NHS
is performing at the moment and really
there seemed to be two prongs to the
government's approach one to put a bit
more money in it but also to try and
reform it now there is that story that
you talk to Steve Barkley about about
getting rid of pen pushers and getting
rid of targets now it was interesting
when you pushed him on whether or not
targets actually helped the patient
rather than gum up the Health Service
because ultimately if you don't have
standard by which doctors and hospitals
are being judged if you don't have
things by which uh uh Health trusts can
be judged against how exactly are people
going to be able to measure which part
the country has a Health Service that's
doing well which parts of the Health
Service are doing less well and need
extra help and need extra Improvement it
struck me that there is a sort of
elephant in the room when it comes to
the Health Service and that is the
Workforce Now Steve Barkley is trying to
present a picture where by long-term
decisions uh taken by him and Jeremy
Hunt years ago do mean that there are
going to be more workers coming on
stream but again it'll be for voters to
judge it's so difficult to sort this out
at the moment thank you very much Sam
there'll be more from Sam at 9 30 today
look at the labor view on that shall we
we can talk to the party Shadow work and
pension secretary Jonathan ashware thank
you for being on the program today now
you're here with a different hat on of
course but you were shadow of Health
secretary for a long time including
during the pandemic we did lots of
interviews on that
um so I do want to start off with the
NHS
um what state do you think the Health
Service is in as we approach winter
well it's in a quite desperate State
isn't it not only are seven million
people on the waiting list I think
around 400 000 people now are waiting
Beyond a year for treatment that's
that's four and a half Wembley stadiums
if you like and of course the typical
weight for somebody who needs treatment
has got has doubled from about seven
weeks to 14 weeks the problem of the NHS
is there's a there's an increased Demand
on the NHS and there simply isn't the
capacity to meet that demand we are
short of the doctors the nurses the
paramedics the clip the clinical stuff
that we need which is why we're in the
labor party have said let's let's impose
the or get get rid of the non-dom tax
status and use as a proceeds from that
to fund extra doctors and nurses but
we're heading into a very difficult
winter a winter that will be miserable
for patients but also it impacts
economic growth we've now got two and a
half million people out of work because
of sickness costing us seven and a half
billion extra in sickness benefits
that's because many of those people
can't work because they're waiting for
mental health treatment although waiting
for an operation now one of the things I
want to do as a work and pension
secretary is use my years of expertise
in in health policy to reform the way in
which we provide support in job centers
and employment services to help those
who are sick uh get back into work
because there's evidence now if you
better integrate Employment Services
with health services with mental health
services you can actually support people
to return to work so the problems in the
Health Service are having a direct
impact on people's ability to go back to
work and our overall economic
performance now the other thing that
Stephen Barkley said in our interview
earlier was that he wouldn't support he
doesn't recognize and wouldn't support
the front page of the Sunday time
suggestion that the government is
considering a closer link to the EU like
a Swiss style relationship so access to
the same Market which of course would
mean things like pay more into the
budget higher immigration and an
increased role for the European courts
of Justice
in principle would labor support that
now what we've talked about is that we
need to make brexit work we obviously
need to deal with the problems in the
brexit deal and isn't it uh you know
ironic that we were told by Boris
Johnson's cabinet which of course Wishy
sunak was a leading member of as
Chancellor that we had this oven ready
deal the one of the best deals possible
and now it appears that conservatives
are briefing suggesting that the deal
isn't working out and they're and they
want to return to something which is
it's something more like Checkers so the
check of the old Checkers proposals look
what we need to do is we need to deal we
need to fix the problems in the deal we
need to look at Veterinary agreements so
we can be dealing with agricultural
products better we need to look at our
security Arrangements we do not need to
look at ways in which we can get more
frictionless trade because although the
volume of trade on the world stage has
improved our exports performance is
still disappointing so there are changes
that need to be made but it is quite
something that conservances appear to be
briefing newspapers or government
sources appear to be beaten newspapers
suggesting that that own deal isn't
working out as they told as it would
okay um do you so you saying though that
the uh the deal is not working but I'm
just trying to work out exactly how far
labor would go to improve the situation
I mean would you be prepared for example
to look at access to the single Market
now we are not proposing returning to
the singles Mark the single Market or
the the Customs Union or anything like
that but we do want to negotiate a
bespoke deal for the United Kingdom and
so that so our businesses can export so
that we can get those agreements on uh
agriculture so we can work together on
security issues but we're not we're not
no one we are not proposing that we just
simply adopt the Swiss proposal which
the government now are apparently
looking at but of course we need to fix
this deal of course we need to make
brexit work because this oven ready deal
that we were promised this great deal
has had has not worked out in the way in
which Rishi sooner and Boris Johnson
tell the British people it would do okay
a couple of other things that I'm Keen
to ask you about nurses are striking
demanding a 17 pay rise should they get
it
look what we very clearly said is that
of course nurses and other public sector
workers deserve a fair pay settlement
but these things need to be negotiated
through the proper way
now Steve Barkley I didn't hear his
interview I'm afraid because I've been
coming from another Studio but it's now
incumbent upon him to get all the Trade
union Representatives the
representatives of nurses doctors
paramedics and so on round a table to
avoid industrial action this winter
because we know the NHS is in a
desperate State and nobody wants to see
our NHS staff we'll go on strike so he
had to get them I just want to come in
if I never out a deal I just want to
come in if I may because obviously you
know ask Steve Barkley about what he's
doing on the NHS strikes but I just want
to get Labor's position you know you
talk about the independent process but
that independent process is not going to
give them a 17 pay rise is it so do up
by that do we assume that labor also
doesn't think that nurses should get the
pay rise that they want
well uh the health sector unions have
rejected the recommendations of the
independent pay review body processes so
it's now incumbent upon the health
secretary who don't forget in
legislation last year took more direct
control of the NHS that was one of the
things I was actually under Matt Hancock
and it's actually Javid but they took
more direct control of the NHS so
there's no hiding the book stops with
the health secretary if he wants to
avoid industrial action this winter he
has to get those trade unions in his
office on Monday morning to get an
agreement and Hammer out an agreement
now we've not got access to all the
facts and figures on in the NHS because
that's government information but I
would be if I but I am sure that if West
streeting was the health secretary he
would be getting the unions in for a
discussion and of course we never had
industrial action in the NHS okay under
a labor government two more quick
questions for you before I have to let
you go
um according to the Observer labor wants
to polish the House of Lords some would
say that they've been the most effective
opposition for 12 years at the last
conservative government
that's of course and I and there's very
good people in the House of Lords but we
need to bring it into the 21st century
it needs to be a modern second chamber
and therefore it should be elected and I
think when trusting politics is so low
because of the actions of Boris Johnson
and he's actually trying to make
appointments to the House of Lords which
people feel or have felt is
inappropriate I think the time is right
to democratize the House of Lords but
this is part of a a commission that will
soon a recommendation from a commission
that will soon be published and all
these matters will have a proper
consultation on how democracy in the
House of Lords what how it could be
implemented uh how the regional voice it
can be part of that and so on
okay and now finally uh the World Cup of
course kicks off uh today and there's
been lots of criticism of Qatar is it
right for us to continue to talk about
this or do you think now perhaps is the
time to focus on uh the sport
I will be watching England uh of course
of course I will and supporting England
obviously
I think we should continue talking about
the issues because a qatar's human
rights record particularly around the
how they treat LGBT people but also the
way in which the workers who have been
building stadiums have lost their lives
and been abused it's quite right that
the world focuses on that as well and
puts pressure on the Qatari government
while at the same time enjoying football
so look I'm going to be watching England
but I think we have to continue to talk
about this very these awful abuses that
we see in Qatar okay thank you very much
indeed Jonathan Ashworth there thank you
are you watching safety Ridge on Sunday
we've got lots still to come on the
program at this morning we are going to
be talking to some immediate reaction to
the health secretary's appearance on the
program with the chief executive NHS
providers Matthew Taylor so that is uh
talking about the NHS again and of
course following the tragic death of
awab ishak you know the little boy who
lost his life because of mold in his
house later well actually immediately I
think we're going to be talking to the
social housing activist equation 20
Bower looking forward to that
uh well let's talk about at that story
now at shall we are we all sort of like
the sound codes we're going to be
talking to Sam after the program in the
take as well I don't want to miss them
out apologies there now to return to the
really tragic story of our ishak now he
if you're a member of course was just
two years old when he died he lived in a
rented flat in Rochdale it was a flat
that was covered in mold that caused a
respiratory disease that killed him now
yesterday the chief executive of the
Housing Association that rented the flat
was sacked after he repeatedly refused
to resign but of course it's not just
Rochdale there are cases of substandard
housing across the country the coroner
who investigated little awab's dare said
that it must be a turning point in those
conditions but is there any sign that
things will change we're joined now by
the social housing activist quojo twenty
Bowen thank you so much for being with
us on the program we really appreciate
it
um the case just breaks my heart at this
little boy I'm sure you must sort of
feel the same yeah I mean it's
absolutely horrific and I've been
campaigning for the last year and a half
to avoid a situation just like this but
what we've seen tragically with the case
of Arab is that he's paid the ultimate
price for um corporate neglect by his
landlord are you surprised
no I can't say I am I mean it's an
absolute tragic case but from what I've
seen across the country in terms of
tenants living under
um social housing landlords whether that
be Housing Association or local
Authority is often they're living in
similar cases in some cases even worse
conditions for decades even I've spoken
to one tenant who reached out to me for
help after complaining for 27 years
that's longer than I've been alive yet
they weren't listened to I think that's
it isn't it the not being listened to
someone talking for 27 years and you
know the lawyers for Arab's parent read
the statement from them they said we
cannot tell you how many health
professionals we've cried in front of
and Rochdale Borough Housing staff we
we've pleaded to expressing concern we
shouted out as loudly as we could I mean
it's just being ignored I mean it's
absolutely devastating his parents
complained before he was even born about
the dampened mold in his property yet
two years on it led to his death that
never should have been the case and I'm
sure they would have been complaining to
the likes of the repairs manager at
Rochdale Borough wide housing and they
haven't been talked about in this whole
conversation and complaints would have
gone directly to them they would have
overseen it and we've seen in the last
24 hours that there's others on Arabs
estate living in similar conditions four
years some people have complained for
this is a systemic issue not just
Rochdale Borough wide Housing
Association but across the sector why do
you think people aren't being listened
to do you think it's because of
resources do you think it's because of
racism with class what do you think it
is I think it's a I think it's a mixture
I mean racism and class does massively
come into it especially from
um my experience but I also think it's a
stigma with social housing tenants it's
a cultural issue within the housing
sector and the fact is landlords can get
away with it due to the lack of
Regulation I mean for example we're
often told civilians nobody is above the
law and I think in the case of bad
landlords they they shouldn't be exempt
from that either especially in cases
like our where it costs the life of an
innocent individual so Gareth swarbrick
has been removed from his post as chief
executive of Rochdale Borough wide
housing that's the Housing Association
that rented the house Michael Gove has
written to every Council leader in
England and social housing provider
do you think that change is coming
well I have to say in the case of
um
the Rochdale Borough wide housings chief
executive having to be fired is an
insult and disgrace and I think it
represents
um the culture again within within
housing and directors boards the fact of
directors boards only 24 hours ago was
agreeing that he should stay in his post
even after that story comes out is
insulting for me so I can't imagine what
it's like
um for the family do I think change
comes change should have come five and a
half years ago after Grenville we should
not be sat here having a conversation
about an innocent two-year-old
um dying as a result of the neglect of
his landlord but here we are and change
really should have come then so I really
hope it does I really hope this sector
wakes up and does their jobs realizes
that it's people's lives they're dealing
with it's not just a nine to five I
think that's what the problem is what
was your message be right now to Michael
Gove you obviously a very eloquent
spokesperson for many many people right
across the country what would your
message be to him well I've met I've
spoken to Michael Gove and his team uh
several times and I'm glad the
regulations coming in it needs to come
in a lot quicker and I don't think we're
being tough enough with bad landlords I
think in cases like this to avoid cases
like this we honestly need criminal
charges now if it was any other sector
if this was the NHS for example and it
was a doctoral nurse who had neglected
their patient in this way and it
resulted to a death Not only would they
be struck off that wouldn't even be
disputed there would also be a criminal
investigation open that we need to see
it in within housing too because it's
people's lives they're dealing with like
I said earlier not just the nine to five
I just want to sort of pause and give
people a bit of a sense about the
conditions that we're talking about I
think we can show a video of the concert
I just woke up and it's getting worse
right absolute ridiculous look at this
right
do you call this condensation what the
hell is that look
that is not a conversation look at this
look and it smells its rank is
disgusting and I'm not putting up with
this right you expect people to live in
conditions like this come on right you
see on the window there's condensation
but the roof shouldn't be looking like
that come on
are you kidding me look at this it
smells and this is destroying the carpet
and the paint
I'll find that social yeah I mean I
posted that um 20 I think 24 hours after
um our story broke a couple of days ago
and I want to bring up this point about
damper mold because it's this
um huge misunderstanding with it and
often it's tenants blame for the
conditions that they're living in with
dampen mold they're told stop drying
your clothes indoors open your windows
turn your radiators on there are 300 000
different types of molds a lot of which
can grow in your homes and many of them
um require different ways to tackle it
however across the sector it's often the
case that landlords send out contractors
like in this case where it's just washed
off with a bit of bleach and they hope
that it doesn't come back or what they
do is they send a contract around to
paint over it and pretend it's not there
that's not how you deal with dampen mold
and now I hope they've learned that with
dampen mold it can cost your life what
kind of conditions do you see honestly
the list goes on I've seen people's
homes flooded with sewage raw sewage
I've seen people's homes filled with
cockroaches damp mice mold ceilings that
have collapsed I've taken tenants to a e
due to a sealing past partially
collapsing on top of them I have seen it
or you wouldn't even let animals live in
these homes the homes that I've seen
um never mind human beings and I think
it's a absolute disgrace that in this
country we allow that to happen with the
resources that we have and I mean with
these housing associations for example
often the chief executives are paid
six-figure salaries or in terms of
surpluses it's in the hundreds of
millions they don't have an excuse about
not having enough money and funding it's
their priorities and lack of care and
talk to me a bit about your story you
know how did you come to be it sitting
here what how did you involved in
campaign so I lived in um poor housing
myself poor social housing and we have
been complaining throughout to our
landlord for many many months if not
years about the district pair we were
living in again cockroaches my stamp
mold kitchen that was nearly 100 years
old rotten no bathroom
um no bathroom light no windows in the
bathroom and we My dad became ill he was
diagnosed with stage one esophageal
cancer in those those conditions that
progressed it was an aggressive form of
cancer progressed to stage four he was
being fed for his stomach by nurses
three times a day in those conditions
they struggled to bathe him and steal
the landlord wouldn't do or fix or
remedy the property he then passed away
and things went from bad to worse we
were left over winter without a living
room ceiling and still they wouldn't
come and deal with the other issues and
I said enough was enough no ceiling on
your living room yes so
um it was three stories and it was the
middle floor and they had the ceiling
had partially collapsed due to a leak
they came and pulled the ceiling down in
October
um 2020 and they didn't put up until
January the following year and they
didn't fix any of the other issues at
that point either and I had just had
enough and turned to social media put
all the images and videos up on there
and it went viral and disgraced the
landlord into not just complete in the
works in my home but spending millions
and having to complete over 800 repairs
on my estate to other people's homes too
because it was falling to bits I'm
really sorry about your dad you know
it's really you know but it does feel
like you know you're used as death to
make huge change for lots of people
thank you um just finally you know be
brutal I am very aware of our
responsibility and do you feel that
sometimes there's too much focus on
people who pay higher rate of tax people
who own their own homes and not enough
on rented housing on social housing
absolutely I think this issue with poor
social housing and social housing and
social housing crisis anyway has existed
um for many decades before I was even
born people have been suffering I think
more needs more Focus needs to be put on
that that's where the real issues are
that's where people's lives are being
put at risk and I sometimes think if um
before 2017 it was seen as a focus and
it was like all over the news and peas
were talking about it could we have
potentially avoided the tragedy that was
grenfell had we had spoken about this
earlier thank you so much for being on
the program it's been really interesting
to talk thank you to see some of the
footage as well really quite sobering
thank you for having me thank you
um pretty shocking I'm really glad to be
covering that story on the program this
morning now of course at the beginning
of the show The Health and Social care
secretary Steve Barkley told us that he
does recognize the NHS is under real
pressure this winter and he thought the
Royal College of nurses paved demands in
his words were unreasonable well we
could speak now to the chief executive
of NHS Confederation that represents a
whole Healthcare System in England Wales
and Northern Ireland that's Matthew
Taylor he joins us now live from uh
Leeds thank you for being with us
um I'm interested to get your take on
the interview with Stephen Barclay first
he said he wants a bonfire of the NHS
pen pushers cutting bureaucrats axing
targets for efficiency savings is that a
good idea
yeah I mean I'm not sure about the kind
of slightly populist language of pen
pushers and red tape and all of that I
mean actually the the issue here is that
the National Health Service is very uh
centralized hierarchical system and it
generates an enormous number of targets
now some of those targets actually come
from politicians themselves
so I strongly support the idea that we
should try to devolve more in the whole
syllabus so that local health systems
working with Partners like local
government can find solutions that work
for them too often these National
systems treat everywhere as if it's the
same and places
um are very different and the secretary
of state is appointed Patricia Hewitt
who of course was Health Secretary of
State way back in the barriers to try to
look at how we can devolve power in the
Health Service so we can assess our
local solution so I we absolutely
support that we think it's a very good
idea
um we are seeing you know I'm interested
to know about the state of the Health
Service because we're seeing of course
long waits in a e we're seeing struggles
to get GP appointments and we of course
go about to go up into winter and the
time when the NHS is under most pressure
are you actually a bit worried about the
health of the NHS right now
yes we are in the midst of a a gap and
that's the gap between the demand that
we've faced and the capacity we've got
so on the one hand we have an aging
population
so for example the year of our lives are
we consuming the most amount of Health
and Care results it's the last year of
our life and over the next decade
there'll be about 25 more people
reaching the last year of their life so
you've got population aging you've got
repent up demands of covid you've got
unfortunately the fact that as a country
we have high levels of poverty poverty
is stroke is strongly connected to ill
health is your last interview vividly
demonstrated so we've got a lot of
demand but then when it comes to
capacity we had 10 years of austerity
when growth in Health Service spending
was around half of what most economists
say that we need that meant we went into
covert there was a research last week
that showed this about about 40 billion
pounds less have been invested in the UK
in comparison to EU countries in that
decade leading up to Cobalt so we go
into covid
with over a hundred thousand vacancies
with a crumbling estate lack of
investment in things like IIT and covet
hits us extremely hard the effects that
covert had in terms of for example
waiting list was much worse in the UK
because we just didn't have that extra
capacity so we've come out of that and
this is the issue this gap between
demand and capacity now you know we
welcome the fact the secretary of state
has got more money out of the treasury
to deal with the impact of inflation
it's not as much as we need not as much
as we want but we're grateful for
anything that we can get but what we
really need now is consistent spending
over the next five or ten years and
we've got to address these two
fundamental issues 130 000 vacancies in
hell so it's 160 000 in Social
and a 10 billion pound backlog in terms
of the estate and it's only when we
fundamentally address those capacity
issues that we're going to get the
Health Service that we need and that we
want
it's interesting for you to talk there
about you know the health of the Health
Service going into uh covid because of
course you know minister is very keen to
talk about the impact of the pandemic
exclusively
um now you're talking now about the
challenges of
um extra Demand with the Aging
population and how much more Health
Service we consume in the later years of
Our Lives
now the NHS of course is consuming an
increasing amount of public spending I
think it's a almost 200 billion pounds a
year 20 of public spending continuing to
rise
is the problem that actually money isn't
the only solution that we need reform as
well
I I do think we can do things better I
think we can be more productive but the
problem is that some of the ways in
which we're not productive are a
reflection of that lack of investment so
let me give you a couple of examples we
spend a lot of money on agency staff and
that's a very expensive way of employing
people but that's because we don't have
that Workforce strategy so one of the
things I really welcome about the Autumn
statement is a commitment by the
government to have a proper medium-term
Workforce strategy take another example
almost every hospital in England in
Wales in Northern Ireland has got Wards
full of people who could go home who
should go home hospitals are not a good
place for me to be if you don't need to
be there you get in a deconditioned your
your situation returns to kind of
deteriorate now it costs more to have
people in hospitals than it does to have
them in Care Homes and a lot more than
it does to have them getting domiciliary
care but we don't have that social Care
staff the lack of investment in capital
means that services like Primary Care
aren't as efficient as they as they
ought to be so we can be more productive
but it's not about kind of you know
cutting away at bureaucracy actually we
have fewer managers in the Health
Service than than most other kind of
systems large large systems like ours
it's about that medium-term investment
in a Better Health Service a Health
Service for example that could be better
at diagnostic so we we find diseases uh
earlier so we all want a more productive
Health Service we all want a Better
Health Service and to be fair to the
Secretary of State I think many of the
things he's talking about whether it's
data I.T evolving power are in the right
direction
but it's going to take time you know we
are not in the situation we want to be
in the demand is growing and it is going
to take time for us to rebuild the
health center
I'm talking about social care were you
disappointed that there wasn't more
about social care in the Autumn
statement
well there's some more money for social
care I mean the government faced a
difficult Choice which is that most of
the extra money that was dedicated to
social care and the Austria's Autumn
statement was going towards the cap on
social care costs now the government has
put that off for two years that's an
unpopular thing to do but by doing that
there's more money which can go into the
front line and I I think on balance
given that resources are limited that
was probably the right thing to do
because when you've got a hundred and
seventy thousand 160 000 vacancies in
Social care this situation just grinds
to a whole
and if you talk to anyone in local
government who's trying to recruit
people into social care the fact is that
you know the cost of living crisis is
hard for everyone but the private sector
in the end can pass on extra costs it
can raise wages and I I speak to people
every day who work in Health and Social
care and they talk about staff leaving
to go and work in warehouses to go and
work in retail something which
intensifies in Crystal so that situation
is deteriorating so in a perfect world
there'd be more money for social care in
the front line and we'd be able to carry
out the reforms that Boris Johnson
unveiled some time ago but given the
choices the really important thing is to
get that money to the front line and and
two for example get those people out of
Hospital who don't need to be there
it's interesting as well to hear talking
about the um issue with staff in the
hospitals but also in Social care as
well his brexit had an impact on that
there's no question that brexit is part
of this and the government themselves
uh has taken measures uh to bring more
staff in from around the world because
you know we have Labor shortages
everywhere and they're particularly
acute in Health and Care because we
don't pay very much and because the work
is extremely demanding but yes brexit
cut off as supply of labor and we've had
to Scrabble around now to try and bring
in people because you know without
overseas staff our NHS simply would not
work
and then finally and you know hundreds
of thousands of nurses have voted to
strike
how much
is that going to have on a Health
Service this winter that as we've
already talked about is already feeling
a lot of pressure
well to be fair to the RCN and the
unions they've committed to the fact
that they will not disrupt uh emergency
or critical care but clearly as you say
Health Service under kind of pressures
I've described
industrial action is just another
pressure on top of that and I welcome
the fact that the secretary of state is
keeping negotiations open keeping
discussions open uh with uh the unions
the government has committed to Bringing
forward the pay review for next year so
hopefully hopefully there are grounds
for finding
um a way through this but it's important
to say that you know even if the trade
unions weren't at weren't threatening
industrial action
with the 130 000 vacancies we have an
issue about who how we recruit how we
retain and how we motivate uh our staff
so we're going to have to look at this
pay issue if we're going to have the
Staffing
um that we need and it's not just about
pay it's also about morale it's about
the workload that people have to deal
with but at the moment as an
organization that represents NHS leaders
all I can say is I hope trade unions and
the government continue to talk find a
way through this and if there is more
money to be made available for pay it is
really important that that money comes
into the Health Service because we don't
have spare capacity to meet higher wage
okay thank you so much for being on the
program uh this morning really
interesting to talk Matthew Taylor
really good to get lots of different uh
views on the NHS and the challenges that
are going forward we've also of course
been focusing on uh the story about our
britishank and looking at housing as
well and we can now speak to the former
children's commissioner for England and
Longfield good to have you on the
program this morning thank you for being
here
now of course you've spent years working
with vulnerable children and families
and are there other young people like
irwob living in dangerous conditions and
What needs to change
I think that's undoubtedly the case from
everything we know everything we hear
from those that are working on the front
line and everything we see on our
screens and I think we should be shocked
by this but we should be really angry
too these are absolutely pointless harms
and needless harms they can be prevented
and that needs to be
um the focus now we heard earlier about
the awful conditions I've seen some of
those
um I have spoken to those families who
live there you know we are talking about
cramped conditions but cold mold rat
infestations places which as the coroner
said in in Arab's case
um really uh are not fit for human
habitations so we can see that the
secretary of state is um uh taking this
forward uh my message to him would be to
make this a mission
um you know it's in plain view it's in
front of us it's one of those things
that compounds so many social problems
around children growing up in poverty
but it needs that determination and
Leadership
for one thing that's you know really
sort of troubled me about this case is
his parents saying we cannot tell you
how many health professionals we've
cried in front of and housing staff
we've pleaded to in an equation as well
saying that you know he's spoken to
people who have been complaining about
things for 27 years but his own family
uh complaining to talking about the
living standards that they were in
before his father died
why is it that some families are
listened to and frankly others are just
a not
well it's a very very common message
from families that they ring they
complain they get ignored
um they have to wait months and years
nothing happens if it happens it's not
fixed properly
um there does seem to be a mix certainly
there's also the element of prejudice
which is wearing its ugly head in this
too
um but expectations just aren't high
enough we should demand more
um yes of course uh cash is is stretch
but that is absolutely no excuse there
has to be much more of a focus on what
tenants are saying and that customer
care which seems almost non-existent
there's almost this kind of
um feeling that you know they should
take it or leave it and I've spoken to
families where they've had to sew for
serve with children be in temporary
housing move across parts of
um their area and of course that has an
impact on not only their physical health
but their mental health their school all
work
family relationships and stresses and
it's part of the misery that we have of
children growing up in poverty and I
think we have to use this not only is
the divining moment for social housing
but also a defining moment for what we
want as a country
um around children growing up and
growing up well and at the moment we've
got four million children living in
poverty not thankfully all in the
Dreadful conditions that we can see
um with um our situation but still being
held back in every part of their life
and it's a waste we're not investing in
Solutions
um we're paying huge amounts to deal
with crisis many many billions
now you have watched a lot of obviously
about on young people you've recently
published a report the commissioner on
young lives
you can understand can't you why young
people feel hard done by today frankly
you know they can't go down the housing
ladder they pay more for the University
education and their parents ever did the
debt burden is ever Rising uh I think
it's a second at highest departmental
expenditure budget under the NHS our
debt interest payments in our young
people right to feel that actually
things are a bit unfair well I think
young people do are you know it is fair
that they look at the world around them
and they think that you know they can
see that they've not been at the
Forefront of decisions that obviously
stuck home to many young people and
children when during the pandemic
schools stayed closed while pubs theme
parks
um and shops opened
um uh so they haven't been at the
Forefront of decision making and for
those I think all children feel it they
also feel that
um there's so much uncertainty about
their future that they simply wouldn't
have felt 10 20 years ago
um but for those kids that are growing
up in very difficult circumstances I
think that there's so many additional
pressures they feel marginalized they
can't see a future they don't have that
hope about getting onto the job ladder
many a fifth of all children leave
school without basic qualifications and
for those children who can't see their
their future and their progress within
you know what we would see as mainstream
they may start to look elsewhere and
we've had a report this week from the
center for social justice that said
there are around two million children
who aren't attending school now
regularly many where parents are taking
them out of school
um and educating them at home because
they've kind of given up on not getting
that support so again really the need to
Target much more help at families and
children to prevent problems and get to
the you know get to the heart of those
social problems rather than
um you know watching them emerge and
then having to pay the very high price
we of course spoke a lot during the
pandemic when you were a children's
commissioner and we know how lockdown
impacted young people and children
whether it was the closure of schools
whether it was people being ordered to
stay in their homes where sadly some
people are you know not in the best
conditions or are not safe are we still
picking up the pieces from that lockdown
and is enough being done
we are and I think we're only just
starting to see what that means of
course NPC this because they see it in
their constituency bags and in their
offices all the time and more and more
are saying to me look I think we're only
just seeing the mental health impact of
the pandemic but it does go much further
than that those children who were living
in the most disadvantaged families the
most disadvantaged areas uh lost more
time in school and are now further back
um we haven't had the kind of almost
childhood recovery that I think was once
envisaged by
um the recovery commissioner that we saw
temporarily early imposed it's been a
very narrow view of recovery and of
course with the cost of living crisis
and families being under more and more
pressure those social problems are only
getting deeper and deeper and frankly
with the thought yes of course there's
been some rest part this week with
benefits and with schools but with the
thought of further cuts to Public
Services coming down the tracks in a
couple of years time that's a terrifying
thought and again much more of an
emphasis needs to be put on investing to
turn those problems around getting
poverty down helping release these
children to have the kind of Futures we
all want because people want growth we
do need to get these children being able
to get to the position where they're
able to have Bright Futures and make the
most of the chances that hopefully will
come their way
thank you so much for being on the
program really interesting to talk as
always Ann Longfield there thank you
and now before we go on to the next part
of the show which is the take where we
have half an hour at look back on the
interviews what we've learned with Sam
Coates a quick reminder our midweek
program the take is back again this
Wednesday now that's our chance to take
the political temperature during the
week it's been quite newsy I guess in
recent months to say the least lots of
interviews with big guests analysis from
our journalists and data and our regular
viewers panel as well now the take live
from Westminster Sky News Wednesdays at
9 00 PM so do join us there we've also
got the safety bridge on Sunday at
podcast which will be available after
the show that's around lunchtime some
highlights on the interviews some
analysis today it will be myself the
daily mirrors John Stevens and our
program editor Scott Beasley so you can
find that And subscribe wherever you get
your podcast safe Ridge on Sunday
podcast that's it for this week's uh
program in a moment we'll be talking
through today's interviews with Sam
capes our Deputy political editor thanks
for joining us this Sunday morning
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to safety Ridge the take where
we look in a bit more detail at some of
the things we talked about with our
guests in the last hour it was a really
busy show we talked about lots of things
from the NHS that was a big Focus for us
to brexit what the government's going to
do about it the impact it's having and
also housing after the really sad death
at that two-year-old little boy it's
really moved me last week so I was glad
that we managed to do some on that on
the program today as well now let's
bring in shall we our Deputy political
editor at Sam coats who is here with us
every Sunday to give his analysis about
some of the big things that are
happening in Westminster thanks for
being with us uh Sam so it feels like
that you know we had the big week this
week with the Autumn statement on
Thursday we're starting to get more of a
sense about who what she seen our kids
and who what some of his priorities are
going to be where are we this morning
well it's fascinating isn't it Sophie
because when we sat there on Thursday we
were watching politics being redrawn
once again eight weeks ago we had a
conservative party that wanted to borrow
to fund tax cuts now you've got a
conservative party that's going to spend
over the next two years more money on
public services but then do deep Cuts uh
they say that they're going to bring
down the debts and the deficit but
actually they're going to borrow more so
we're all having to get our heads around
quite fast
um quite quickly changing situations and
so frankly is the opposition and as you
say it was a really busy show there were
lots of different subjects on the agenda
but but if I had one reflection about
the whole show
in the round it's that when you listen
to this iteration of the conservative
party and this iteration of the labor
party the actual policies that they're
putting forward the suggestions that
they're making on that difficult
different and when I listened to
Jonathan Ashworth basically what he
seemed to be saying was we don't have an
alternative plan to the conservatives we
would just do pretty similar uh goals
but try and do it better and whether
that's sorting out nurses pay the
direction of the NHS yes there'd be a
bit more funding from labor but it's not
a transformationally different plan to
the one being put forward by Steve
Barkley this morning or when it comes to
brexit which is the subject that I want
to uh want us to start by talking with
um then basically labor would come in
and have pretty similar gold but they
think they can just do it better and
that discussion about brexit has all
been fired off by probably quite a
controversial article on the front page
of the Sunday Times this morning
suggesting that the new Rishi sunak
government in yet another change of
Direction uh just one of so many we've
had recently in uh when it comes to
brexit once a much closer relationship
with the European Union than the one
being pioneered either by Boris Johnson
or by Liz Trump and that of course is
going to end up being very controversial
not least uh with the conservative party
and so the government's doing a bit of
firefighting this morning
well I don't support that I want to
maximize uh the opportunities that
brings it up that's what I worked for as
brexit secretary and as the minister
responsible for Life Sciences I see huge
opportunities for the UK and being
agilely moving at PACE and having a
regulatory system that is absolutely
tailored to the the UK needs it's in
both sides interests to remove barriers
we traded with each other we're
important Partners to each other so
that's mutually beneficial and of course
we want to work constructively with EU
Partners to do that
that was Steve Barkley there as you were
saying on uh brexit it was quite
interesting talking about his reaction I
thought to the Sunday Times uh story he
really pulled cold water on it and I was
just trying to work out how much of that
is number 10's line they want to kill
the story off it's not going to happen
or how much of it is Steve Barkley
because he doesn't like it he obviously
back-breaks it what's your sort of
reading of that
so undoubtedly Steve Barkley and
committed brexit doesn't doesn't like it
um I I think I mean if I'm being honest
Sophie the I don't recognize formulation
which is the one that Steve Barkley used
about the Sunday time story is perhaps
at the less categorical end of the
various denials they I think there's no
doubt the number 10 on Steve bikes you
don't like this story being out there
but but that that's different to it not
necessarily being true what is certainly
true is that ministers want fewer
barriers when it comes to trading with
the EU and what's just a fact of life is
that in order to achieve that you need
to do things uh in a more similar way to
the European Union there's lots of
discussion at the moment uh from
commentators about whether or not the
end of Liz truss and the way that Rishi
sunak has begun uh the kind of governing
style that he's got does mean that we're
going to end up with something a little
bit closer to the European Union uh than
had been envisaged by Boris Johnson and
that that that does feel to me quite
quite likely the government's going to
just not want to talk about what the
Sunday Times right but it can't escape
it forever very soon it's got to set out
its approach to the Northern Ireland
element of brexit which will either
result in a closer relationship perhaps
more use of European Court in Northern
Ireland or it's going to result in an
Unholy row as ministers say that we
can't put up uh with the kinds of uh
agreements that Europe want in order to
maintain a a a kind of closer
relationship we will know soon enough
the government can't duck this even if
they claim not to recognize what to do
and it's not like the opposition are
proposing that we do things dramatically
differently that's key isn't it Sam um
it's interesting isn't it because you
know we had Steve barked on the one hand
saying no no we do not want a closer
Swiss style relationship but it's not
what we want and then we also had
Jonathan Ashworth uh from labor who I
asked basically the same question too
and I have to say he gave a pretty
similar answer I thought Steve Barkley
let's have a listen
we need to make brexit work we obviously
need to deal with the problems in the
brexit deal we do not need to look at
ways in which we can get more
frictionless trade because although the
volume of trade on the world stage has
improved our exports performance is
still disappointing so there are changes
that need to be made but it is quite
something that conservatives appear to
be briefing newspapers or government
sources appear to be beaten newspapers
suggesting that that own deal isn't
working out as they told as it would
uh Jonathan Ashworth uh there you know
he also did say didn't he that you know
labor aren't looking at getting more
access to the single Market I mean is it
one of those issues brexit where labor
just don't want to talk about it anymore
I mean essentially yes again I think
that labor and the conservatives have a
much closer alignment in terms of their
position than they really like to admit
neither labor nor the conservative party
want to take us back into the single
Market neither labor nor the
conservative party are currently talking
about taking us back into the uh Customs
Union neither Laban or the conservative
party uh want to revive freedom of
movement movement to allow people to go
and live and work in other European
countries and allow them to come uh here
to do the same but within that I think
the choice is whether or not to have a
substantially closer relationship and
this is the as it were the option
pioneered by Theresa May you might for
those of us who've got the brexit
survivors Badge of the last five years
remembered something called the checkers
deal which with all of that framework of
not being part of European institutions
nevertheless maintained very close
relations with the EU which meant that
we would be following their rules that
was her plan she was turfed out of
office by conservatives for doing that
and Boris Johnson became prime minister
it just sounds to me as if there are
bits of government that are going back
to that plan but the question is my God
it was toxic then even if public opinion
is changing a bit and there are some
polls to suggest that it is is that a
sensible route for Richie sunac with
barely the smallest of mandates to be
thinking about going down right now you
know Sam
um in my job people often ask who's your
your fantasy uh guest if you could
interview anyone in the world who would
you like to interview and I have to say
Theresa May would be quite high up my
list I would love to do an interview
with Theresa May but she just she
doesn't do very much at all does she but
there's so much that I think she would
be quite fascinated on right now
and if I'm being honest the the fantasy
interview is Theresa May being honest
because we remember many many interviews
with Theresa May when she was prime
minister she hates being interviewed and
she clams up and doesn't say anything so
Theresa made 2.0 the kind of you know
Unbound Edition would be interesting
Theresa May as we got during her PM
years maybe less so yeah that's actually
a very good point maybe Theresa may not
realizing she's being interviewed in the
pub with a glass of wine uh would be the
one to go for Sam thank you very much
[Laughter]
thank you very much lots more uh coming
up after the break we will be here a
time to digest uh all the things that we
learned on the show lots in the NHS to
come
[Music]
of course a big build up we are so
hopeful at the end of the summer and it
got scrubbed um and then it we were
hoping again
um in early October no no go but yeah
now now we've actually you know we've
had that amazing launch and the the
society nearly didn't go again
apparently they fixed it with a spanner
in the last minute I mean we was quite
incredible isn't it and we've got
there's a whole load of technology and
of course there's I mean isn't that 489
different criteria um for go or no-go
and that didn't include a valve that
didn't quite you know wasn't wasn't
quite tight enough and I guess it's the
temperature that changes that tends to
open these things but yes the the the
technicians who actually made that
happen and all hats off to them and the
teamwork that went with it why do we
want to go to the Moon oh I mean I
suppose we will talk about going back to
the Moon because yes we've been before
haven't we um the moon will allow us to
find out an awful lot more about not
only our own Planet it will allow us to
find out more about what we need to do
to go to Mars it'll open up what we're
hoping to be as a lunar economy as well
so um materials that we can't make
anywhere else that we can produce on the
moon partly to use in space that we
might use let's say for satellites to be
able to beam energy clean energy back
down to us on Earth or perhaps it's just
materials that we can use on Earth in in
other Industries so there's a whole load
of different reasons to go different
spin-offs but I think the main thing is
really it's on the way to going to Mars
to be quite honest right now it's a it's
a really hot time politically it it we
could have done it sooner if we wanted
to but it is expensive and we've got
lots of different priorities and pools
on money yes we need education we need
our Healthcare we've got global economy
that's been up and down and there's so
many things going on but um but in the
end it's been decided that because of
China and the the Chinese desire to
return to go to the moon and they
haven't been yet
um but um there's this race to get
particularly to the South Pole where
there might be ice and other important
minerals particularly rare Earths so um
yeah there is now a political reason to
go to the moon now rather than 10 years
ago would you like to go oh I'd love to
go I think um yeah I can't imagine
there's an astronaut who would say they
would not want to go to the Moon Yeah
and um and of course then ultimately to
Mars that's got to be the real big
ticket destination
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
hello welcome back to safety Ridge on
Sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews and we
have some analysis from our adaptive
political editor Sam Coates as well now
a big focus at this week was the Health
Service it's certainly something that is
really concerning lots of people today
and also as we go into winter a e wait
times whether it's trying to find your
GP and all of that as well um let's
bring in Sam at this point shall we
there was more money for the Health
Service wasn't there in the Autumn
statement
but frankly you know when I look at
these graphs and particularly that A and
E graph that just shows that huge spike
in people waiting more than 12 hours to
see someone in a e it's actually really
quite troubling isn't it
it is there were three things that got
more money in the Autumn statements
schools social care and the NHS and
obviously social care in the NHS the
governments are very keen to link uh as
solutions to uh to pretty much two sides
of the same uh coin as a problem but the
situation is extremely troubling whether
it was those voters that Fraser Moore
talked to this guy correspondent who
heard just how people's personal
experiences were so bad uh all the
graphs the shared data that shows that
the situation for weights in a e and
lots of other metrics is just as as dire
as it can be uh the situation with the
NHS is very bad now one of the things I
was most struck by this morning is it's
quite clear that ministers think that
there's a bit of a silver bullet answer
they are blaming the coronavirus
pandemic and they think that that can be
used to justify and explain the bad
situation of the NHS uh it's quite
clearly something that everybody would
understand but when you listen to
Matthew Taylor now he is the head of the
NHS Confederation which has ties to all
the NHS trust Chief Executives up and
down the country so he has a a very
close eye view on what's going on his
point was that actually you've got to
accept that the NHS wasn't in a great
situation before the pandemic came along
now waiting list might have been lower
uh waiting times might have been lower
but he says that there has been years of
underfunding so as it were the system
was a bit more brittle a bit more
fragile which is why the UK health
system has responded far worse to
coronavirus than perhaps some in
comparative countries yeah let's have a
listen as you say I thought was really
interesting that qualification from
Matthew Taylor after Steve Barkley was
telling us about the impact of the
pandemic let's have a listen waiting
list was much worse in the UK because we
just didn't have that extra capacity so
we've come out of that and this is the
issue this gap between demand and
capacity now you know we welcome the
fact the secretary of state has got more
money out of the treasury to deal with
the impact of inflation it's not as much
as we need not as much as we want but
we're grateful for anything that we can
get
it's always interesting doing interviews
with people like Matthew Taylor isn't it
I think it's actually quite important on
a day when you have like the Secretary
of State who is pushing the government
line to have someone who like broadly
supportive of the government but also
saying hang on a minute that wasn't
quite right
that's right Matthew tell you an
interesting individual of course he
worked as a policy advisor to Tony Blair
and so uh would fairly be characterized
by ministers in a conservative
government uh as somebody with labor
credentials but the truth is that he was
on the wing of the labor party that was
at the most reformist perhaps the
closest when it comes to policy ideas uh
to much of the uh the uh many of the
people inside the conservative party so
I think he's a he's an interesting voice
and more broadly what Matthew Taylor was
doing was saying I quite I don't quite
like the language that Steve bark is
using when it comes to the kind of
changes that he's going to try and do to
the Health Service he doesn't like this
idea of slashing pen pushers uh dealing
with bureaucracies uh not least because
it's a bit demoralizing not least
because the idea that you'd have nurses
and doctors dealing with payroll and
bureaucracy possibly isn't the best use
of their time but he says there does
need to be a conversation about the way
that the NHS is managed and and when it
comes to discussions about things like
Target he was far more open to that
discussion perhaps even than than I was
expecting so so actually
um quite a nuanced message certainly not
all critical uh from Matthew Taylor I I
think people like Steve Barkley the the
new old new health secretary uh we'll um
uh will take some comfort from that yeah
it was interesting I thought Sam wasn't
it what he said on targets because this
is the big story that uh Steve Buckner
was briefing uh today it's on the front
page of the mail on Sunday uh talking
about the bonfire of the pen pushers the
one thing that I did want to pick up on
in the interview with Steve Barkley was
where he was also talking about
scrapping some Targets this is what he
said when I addressed that there is a
place for targets but they've
everything's a priority nothing so
priority and risk in my view is best
assessed on a population basis through
the icbs by local leaders they're better
able to tailor the priorities for their
local needs and we will have information
such as important right of course of
course and no one's suggesting we don't
have any Targets but what I'm saying is
there's a 2.8 billion pounds do you want
to get rid of the target such as any
waiting time no I think the a e is a
very useful Target in terms of actually
the wider system Health within the NHS
and it speaks to flow which is a key
issue in terms of ambulance under delays
and people waiting in a e
some the target thing I think is
important because you know it's easy to
look at this and think yeah great let's
just get rid of all that waste we want
to spend money on doctors we want to
spend money on hospitals
but actually I guess my point on targets
that I was trying to make is how do we
assess how well the house service is
doing you know whether that's people you
know in the sector but also people like
you and I when we're challenging
ministers on whether or not the targets
are being met
I think that's absolutely right and you
know through the whole of the last 25
years of discussion about uh how to
manage the Health Service these issues
are rattled around and we've lurched in
terms of policy from one end of the
scale to the other new labor back in
1997 brought in quite a lot of specific
targets but as the years went by there
was a fear that those targets became as
it were almost distorting because uh
doctors would try and ensure people
received a certain type of appointment
in a e within a certain time but that
actually meant that the health care
given to those individuals was secondary
because meeting this artificial metric
became the priority inside a e and so we
looked again and Charlie's became looser
and then but then there was a fear that
there wasn't enough uh pressure being
put on the Health Service to deliver and
so we went back in the other direction
again and we've been round and round
this debate for 25 years if not longer
it's a very hard one to strike a balance
on I thought it was quite interesting
also it is another area where we're
going backwards and forwards Steve
Barkley suggesting that really
accountability lies with the people
managing local trusts now again we
flip-flopped as a country on this uh
under Andrew landsley under David
Cameron's government in 2010 to 2015
essentially a lot of the decision making
about the NHS was pushed off to
Independent bodies uh Minister's message
was don't blame us if things go wrong
then more recently as a result of the
pandemic ministers felt that they didn't
have enough control of the Health
Service so under Boris Johnson and Matt
Hancock they pulled back the powers to
themselves and now Steve Barkley again
talking about the need for local
accountability for local decision making
I I think that's the kind of thing that
the Health Service finds quite difficult
to deal with when there are big
structural changes being done often for
more political uh than reforming good
reforming reasons and that can cause
quite a lot of disruption but the bottom
line is there are no easy answers and
neither uh answer is a is a silver
bullet yeah certainly I'm also
interested Sam on your take on where the
debate is is between the two parties on
some NHS things so before we get your uh
take on that let's have a little listen
to uh Jonathan Ashworth now he's the
shadow working pension secretary but of
course he was had a health secretary for
an awfully long time so it's an issue
that he cares a lot about and I was
interested to talk to him specifically
about nurses we know of course that the
Royal College of Nursing striking for
the first time in their history do they
deserve the pay rise that they're asking
for this is what he told me
the book stops with the health secretary
if he wants to avoid industrial action
this winter he has to get those trade
unions in his office on Monday morning
to get an agreement and Hammer out an
agreement now we've not got access to
all the facts and figures on in the NHS
because that's government information
but I would be if I but I am sure that
if West streeting was the health
secretary uh he would be getting the
unions in for a discussion and of course
we never had industrial action in the
NHS under a labor government
now Sam um I feel like I'm asked getting
that response quite a lot from labor at
the minute we don't have access to all
the facts and figures so I can't answer
your question
yes uh and uh and there's another part
of the answer as well which is but don't
worry if we were in power we would just
be doing it better
that's a lot of things to take on trust
to be honest Sophie uh the labor message
this morning whether it's on brexit
whether it's on the NHS uh whether it's
on pay Rises has all been uh we're not
going to set out a different cause but
we are just better people at doing this
stuff and it's a question for voters
whether or not they they believe them
and go along with that on the base of
frankly at the moment what's what's
quite a quite a thin answer sure
politics has changed a lot in the recent
weeks because of the conservative
turmoil uh and sure it's going to take
some time for labor to cut to catch up
and change its response in relation to
the new government but uh but you're not
getting a lot out of Labor uh
politicians at the moment in terms of uh
in terms of cold hard firm facts in
order to work out uh where they stand
that's different seems to be working
though if you look at the polls
uh one poll had the labor party 21
points ahead this morning and I think if
the poll lead stays like that you're
going to start getting some Panic from
the Tory benches I think labor are being
helped by the fact that there is so much
turmoil inside the conservative party
and while fats uh Autumn statement uh
whilst the statement on Thursday by
Jeremy Hunt and Richie select was
designed to calm the waters there's the
potential for so much more Tory trouble
ahead whether it's on the reaction to
those tax Rises worries about what would
happen after the next election to Public
Services the worries we were just
talking about when it comes to a softer
uh brexit a closer relationship with the
EU how will uh Tory MPS deal with that
and the Myriad of other difficult issues
that Tories are having to get to Grapple
with as they have the third prime
minister in this Parliament one who
doesn't have a mandate from the Tory
members none of this is easy in the end
to terminal might just carry the labor
party into Power Sam thank you very much
indeed that is it from suffrage on
Sunday uh this morning very quick
reminder check out our podcast it should
be a good one this week we've got John
Stevens from The Daily Mirror scoop
machine joining us so definitely want to
watch in the meantime hope to see you on
Wednesday 9pm for safety Ridge for take
[Music]
um